امريكا اعلنت الحرب رسميا على تيك توك
والبيت الابيض رسميا اصدر قرار امس من
مكتب الرئيس عنوانه لتكتوك على اجهزه
الدوله القرار بيمهل الهيئات الحكوميه 30
يوم لحذف تطبيق تيك توك من اجهزه موظفيها
والانظمه الحكوميه والسبب هو المخاطر اللي
بيشكلها التطبيق المملوك لشركه بايت دانس
الصينيه على الامن القومي الامريكي
وطبعا في كلام كثير في الغرب عن سيطره
الحكومه الصينيه على الشركه المالكه
للتطبيق ومخاوف من انها تكون بتستخدمه
للتجسس وفي ديسمبر الكونغرس كان صوت على
مشروع قرار بيمنع الموظفين الفيدراليين من
استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه الحكوميه ومن
بعده عده وزارات ولايات بشكل منفرد حضرت
تيك توك من الاجهزه المملوكه للدوله او
الاجهزه الشخصيه لموظفي الدوله اذا
بيستخدموها للعمل مو بس امريكا على فكره
المفوضيه الاوروبيه التابعه
الاتحاد الاوروبي اصدرت قرار مماثل بيحضر
تيك توك من اجهزه المؤسسه وموظفيها وقالت
انه هذا اجراء لحمايه البيانات وتعزيز
الامن الالكتروني وكندا كمان اخذت نفس
القرار ورئيس حكومتها قال انه قرار لازم
يخلي حتى المواطنين يفكروا في امن
بياناتهم الخاصه والبرلمان الاوروبي من
ساعات اعلن نفس الشيء
المشركه اللي هي المالكه لتيك توك واللي
من سنوات بتنفي اي صله لها بالحكومه
الصينيه وبتعتبر الموضوع بمجرد اكاذيب
علقت على القرار على لسان المتحدث باسمها
بانه المخيب للامال وان الدول ما عدت ايش
مخاوفها من التيك توك ولا ناقشتها او
تشاورت مع الشركه الحكومه الصينيه كمان من
جانبها هي ما سكتت وهذا كان تعليقها على
اليسار
تفاعلكم من مستخدميه تيك توك ومن طرف او
حتى لنا راي او موقف في الحرب اللي شغاله
بين الغرب والصين حول التطبيق لكن لازم
كمان ننوه لملاحظه مو احنا الوحيدين اللي
شايفينها يعني بصراحه هذه الملاحظه بتحط
علامات استفهام كبيره على الموقف الصيني
فالصين اللي بتدافع عن التطبيق وبتنفع
علاقتها فيه وبتسخر من الغرب الخائف منه
ورغم انه التطبيق تابع لشركه صينيه لكنها
حرمه مواطنيها من التطبيق وحاضرته هي
نفسها داخل البلاد وسامحه للمواطنين
يستخدموا التطبيق شبيه لكن في تعديلات
التطبيق اسمه وهو مملوك للشركه نفسها
وبختلف عن تيك توك بانه اولا مصمم بضوابط
وقيود بتحمي الشباب مثل انه بيتم الطلب من
المستخدمين اللي بتقل اعمارهم عن 14 سنه
استخدام وضع اسمه وضع المراهقين وهذا
الشيء بيخلي التطبيق متاح للاستخدام 40
دقيقه في اليوم بس بين الساعه 6:00 الصبح
عشره المساء علشان يلحقوا يناموا عدد
ساعات كافيه خوارزميات وكمان مختلفه عن
خوارزميات تيك توك فهي بدل ما تعرض مقاطع
فيديو راقصه وتحديات متنوعه بتعرض محتوى
ملهم علمي وتعليمي وتاريخي للصين وبتروج
للتمسك الاجتماعي والوطنيه والتطلعات
الشخصيه كمان عنده اجراءات وقائيه براقب
فيها الوقت اللي بيقضيه الشباب على المنصه
وانواع المحتوى اللي بيشاهدوه يعني الصين
خايفه على ادمغه شبابها وثقافتهم والمحتوى
اللي بيشوفوا لكن في نفس الوقت بتصدر
للعالم اللي خايفه منه عادي يعني كده
نعرف المهم للحديث ممكن يعرف هذا الموضوع
اكثر او اكيد الموضوع اكتر معانا من
الرياض الخبير التقني عبد العزيز الحمادي
اهلا فيك معانا عبد العزيز يعني اول شيء
يخلينا نبتدي من اللي هي الاخبار اللي
جالسه العاجله اللي جالسه بتجي من امس عن
الحكومات ومنعها للتطبيق على هواتف
الموظفين الرسميين والهواتف الحكوميه وما
الى ذلك برايك هل هو يعني حركه سياسيه ولا
لا فعلا خوف مبرر
طبعا ساره هذا يعني جزء بسيط من الحرب
الالكترونيه القائمه ما بين الشرق والغرب
اليوم الحرب الجديده هي حرب تطبيقات حرب
امتلاك عدد مستخدمين حرب بيانات حرب
منتجات اكثر من انها تكون حرب عسكريه كما
كانت في السابق اليوم الصين جالسه فعليا
تهاجم الغرب بطريقه جدا
مستمره عن طريق المنتجات الصينيه اللي
نشاهدها ونشاهد انها جالسه تزيد بشكل كبير
جدا العملاق الصيني ولا التيك توك وتيك
توك في اقل من ست سنوات وصل عدد
المستخدمين في الى اكثر من مليار مستخدم
لو قارناه بعدد من المنتجات الاخرى مثل
سناب شات ولا غيره وجدنا انها في غضون
اكثر من عشر سنوات حتى ما وصلت الى 700
ولا 800 مليون مستخدم فلذلك هذا هذا
التطبيق البسيط اللي يستخدمه اكثر من 250
مليون امريكي 200 اكثر من 250 تحميل
مليون تحميل من امريكا لوحدها اكثر من 150
مليون تحميل في اوروبا لوحدها بطبيعه
الحال اكيد هذه البيانات اليوم وين وين
متاحه متاحه في الصين اذا ارادت الصين
معرفه يعني بيانات الاوروبيين والامريكان
بضغط الزر واحده عن طريق تطبيق يسمى تيك
توك بامكانها الاستحواذ عليها بطبيعه
الحال هذا هذا جزء 4 يعني هذا الشيء مو
نفسه ينطبق على فيسبوك على حتى يعني على
تليفوناتنا والشركات المصنعه لتليفوناتنا
طبعا اكيد الناس تنطبق عليها بشكل كامل
اليوم اذا استخدمنا امريكا تمتلك معلومات
عننا ايضا طول الوقت
صحيح ولكن يعني الصين اليوم على سبيل
المثال هي يعني تستخدم هذه في بطبيعه
الحال في معلومات استخباراتيه تستخدم في
كذا في اليوم الامريكي على سبيل المثال هي
قائمه في يعني نستطيع القول شبه حرب بارده
ما بين امريكا والصين في ذلك كل جهه تريد
الحد من المعلومات التي تستخدمها يستخدمها
الطرف الاخر عنها اليوم على سبيل المثال
امريكا جالسه تدعم الشركات الامريكيه
لايجاد بدائل لتيك توك تيك توك طبعا الحرب
ما بينها وبين الحكومه الامريكيه مو جديده
نحن نتكلم عن قرابه اربع سنوات من عام
وسجال كبير جدا ما بين الحكومه الامريكيه
وتكتك الشركات الامريكيه
الرئيس الامريكي ترامب
صحيح تماما فاليوتيوب انتجت يوتيوب شورت
انستقرام انتجت انستجرام ريلز يعني
تحارب او تنافس بشكل كبير جدا
التطبيق الصيني تيك توك لكن بطبيعه الحال
هذه الحرب اكيد ستستمر لن تتوقف كل شركه
تحاول
السياسيه التجاريه بالدرجه الاولى اكثر من
مع استخباراتيه ما تحس هذا الشيء
طبعا اكيد هي نستطيع القول على انها
تجاريه وايضا في نفس الوقت من يملك
البيانات وهي يملك صناعه القرار اليوم
الحكومه الصينيه مثل ما ذكرتي في التقرير
ساره لديها تيك توك للخارج ولكن لديها صح
كيف نقدر نفسره
ان الحكومه الصينيه تحاول يعني ابقاء
البيانات الصينيه داخل الصين يعني اليوم
ممنوع الصينيين استخدام جوجل ممنوع عليها
باستخدام عدد من تطبيقات الامريكيه هل هذا
فقط تجاري لا اكيد تجاري وايضا سياسي
طبيعه الحال اليوم ليس فقط
على سبيل المثال عدد مستخدمين في الصين او
التحميلات في الصين تجاوزت اثنين مليار
تحميل فقط داخل داخل
التطبيق الثاني مو تيك توك
لا التطبيق الثاني الباي دانس عفوا اللي
هو التطبيق اخر اسمه
هذا التطبيق مشابه لتيك توك لتحميلاته
بمئات ايوه
صحيح لذلك هذه التطبيقات الصينيه تدعمها
بشكل كبير جدا حتى تقلل من استخدام
الصينيين للتطبيقات امريكيه والحد من
مشاركه البيانات مع الحكومات الغربيه طيب
يعني اذا لما يطلعوا اليوم الصينيين
ويقولوا للامريكان والدول الاوروبيه وكندا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكذا انه اكون انتم ايش
بكم
يعني هم كانهم بيعكسوا الكلام عن نفسه
كمان يعني رمتني بدائها وانسلت
صحيح طبعا اليوم كل واحده فعليا هي بحاجه
للاخر بطبيعه الحال ولكن اتفق مع كلامك
طيب الان بس لو تشرح سريعا عبد العزيز ايش
خطوره لما شخص او دوله تملك هذا النوع من
المعلومات
طبعا اليوم
الاستخدامنا لمعلومات مثلا على سبيل
المثال الصين لماذا تقوم بالحد من يعني
استخدام الصينيين
للتطبيقات الامريكيه هم ينظرون من منظور
انه اليوم اذا كانت معلومات الصينيه ثلاثه
مليار شخص صيني معلوماتهم موجوده في احد
في احد
الذي احد الحكومات بطبيعه الحال سيستطيعون
التحكم
بثقافه هذا الشعب سيستطيعون التحكم
بالاعلانات سيستطيعون التحكم
كيف يفكر هذا الشعب بشكل كامل راينا مثال
قريب لي كيف تحكمت الحكومه الروسيه عن
طريق فيسبوك بالانتخابات الامريكيه في عهد
ترامب كيف استطاعت ان تميل يعني بنتائج
الانتخابات بشكل
اتهامات لم تثبت ويعني روسيا نفتها يعني
لكن طبيعه الحال يستطيع من يملك البيانات
توجيه هذا الاستخدام بطريقه او باخرى الى
ما يريده
نهايه طبعا حتى المرشحين بيستخدموا برضه
بيشتروا بيانات المستخدمين عشان يعرفوا
كيف يتوجهوا لهم في الاعلانات وما الى ذلك
نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا من
الرياض الخبير التقني عبد العزيز الحمادي
شكرا لك عبد العزيز
[موسيقى]